[Música]
gracias qué tal vamos a hacer un pequeño
ejercicio de necesidad les parece
por favor alza la mano si alguna vez te
has sentido sobrecargado porque crees
que si no haces tú las cosas nadie más
las bases
gracias
yo he pasado que planeas perfectamente
tu día y de repente viene todo el mundo
ya sé lo que es y le da la gana y te lo
echó a perder
eres de los que les gusta acomodar la
ropa por colores en el closet
no se hagan
alguna vez has volteado el rollo de
papel de baño porque la orilla tiene que
ir para el otro lado
si contestaste que si alguna de estas
preguntas felicidades
eres un controlador que se asume pero si
crees que sólo tú con madre controlar
entonces eres un controlador en negación
y es que controlar es perfectamente
normal
yo me confieso soy santo inmoral y soy
controladora en remisión
quizá es porque fui la única o por una
huella de abandono y rechazo en la
infancia podría también ser porque soy
virgo dicen
el caso es que desarrolle fuertemente
este mecanismo de defensa llamado
control aunque yo la verdad creo que soy
bastante flexible obvio siempre y cuando
las cosas se hagan como yo digo
y es que en realidad todos todos
controlamos porque venimos cableados de
fábrica para sobrevivir para preservar
la especie y evitar el sufrimiento yo
digo que todos traemos un chango loco en
la cabeza que vive bastante paranoico
porque su trabajo es estar
constantemente alerta de cualquier
peligro inminente
este pobre chango está todo el tiempo
tratando de casarse lo que nos puede
hacer sufrir
entonces vamos por la vida pretendiendo
controlarlo todo y a todos para que nada
nos las m y nada pueda sorprendernos
controlas tu matrimonio para que sea
perfecto y punto un divorcio
controlar la vida de tus hijos para que
estén cerca de ti y se van a vivir al
extranjero
controlar la zona distancia y punto que
estornudan en la cara
y es que en realidad el control es
ilusorio porque nada allá afuera está
bajo nuestro punto
la vida lleva su propio flujo de su
propio cauce no el que nosotros queremos
en realidad este miedo y esta necesidad
a controlar lo de afuera surge del pavor
en no poder controlarlo de adentro
de que se desborden el miedo y la
ansiedad no puedan manejarlos o de que
me deprima tanto y me duela y no pueda
rearmar me de nuevo entonces caemos en
la represión y el control emocional en
no darnos permiso de sentir porque es
incómodo y es normal
y esto es algo que se ha vendido
insistiendo tras general generación tras
generación se nos ha dicho que sentir no
es bueno porque nos hace débiles no
llores hay pareces vieja muy estás
histérica ya no es para tanto que no
eres no estés triste y la reina de todas
échale ganas o no
y entonces lo que sucede es que vamos
generando una olla express sin válvula
que se vuelve una bomba de tiempo o
generamos un caparazón alrededor de
nuestro corazón para que no sienta y no
nos duela
lo paradójico es que ese caparazón y esa
aparente fortaleza y rudeza que nos da
el control nos hace sumamente frágiles
porque nos hace fríos poco tolerantes
controladores y eso mata la innovación
la creatividad y el aprendizaje total
nos volvemos unos analfabetas
emocionales
el control tóxico de las emociones es el
enemigo número uno de la resiliencia
cuando no nos damos permiso de sentir
nos desconectamos en la realidad de
alguna manera
entonces normalmente lo que hacemos es
que controlamos nos adormece moss y nos
desconectamos
cuando esto sucede empezamos a generar
una serie de mecanismos y de fantasías
catastróficas de lo que puede llegar a
pasar si las cosas no salen como
nosotros las planeamos buenos generamos
ideas fijas de cómo deben ser las cosas
y eso nos hace poco residentes
en esta vida yo he tenido enormes
oportunidades para aprender a soltar del
control se acuerdan que les dije que era
yo muy controladora pues en la
universidad de canela puedo de la
subcomandante gorda
a un grado llegaría mi nivel de control
de plano
la gente me tenía miedo así se las pongo
entonces cuando estamos sufriendo porque
en realidad estamos sufriendo pero no
nos damos cuenta porque no sentimos nos
desconectamos y nos acaba sucediendo que
nos rompemos y como muestra un botón en
el 2020 se vinieron a disparar los
niveles del malestar emocional y
psicológico con esta pandemia por qué
pues porque todos se nos salió de
control a todos y no hemos sabido cómo
manejar las emociones
hay que aprender a sentir las emociones
y gestionarlas
estas oportunidades que a mí la vida me
dio para soltar el control empezaron con
un divorcio que le dio al traste a la
historia de y vivieron felices para
siempre
ouch
luego mi hijo cayó enfermo con una
insuficiencia renal terminal que lo puso
al borde de la muerte y que no estuvo
prácticamente un año entrando y saliendo
de hospitales hasta encontrar el
maravilloso regalo de un trasplante ahí
me di cuenta de que yo no podía
controlar su salud y que tenía que
depender de otros para salvarlo
pero ejercicio absoluto control de mis
emociones por miedo al venirme abajo
a los cuatro meses del trasplante de mi
hijo
la diagnosticada fui yo con cáncer de
mama
estoy segura de que fue mi cuerpo
encapsulando en un humor todo el miedo
el dolor la impotencia el no me di
permiso de sentir durante la enfermedad
de mi hijo
serio la paciente me trajo enormes
oportunidades para aprender a sortear el
control para empezar el de mi propio
cuerpo
y también me dio enormes bofetadas de
humildad al darme cuenta de que yo no
podía sola
y que tenía que aprender a pedir ayuda y
aceptarlo y recibirla como llegará sin
ponerme exigente gran lección
después me volví a casar controladora y
terca
y a los 40 después del cáncer y como un
milagro sorpresivo llega un tercer hijo
que por supuesto volvió a poner todos
los planes de cabeza
después porque aún hay más
perdí mi trabajo corporativo de 12 años
y con eso perdí absoluto control de mis
finanzas
y remate con un segundo divorcio
y no fue hasta ese momento que
verdaderamente tomé
el caparazón de mi corazón explotó en
mil pedazos y me lo dejó en carne viva
expuesto sin más remedio que sentir todo
el dolor de esta circunstancia y en
todas las anteriores que no me había
dado permiso de sentir
literalmente descubre
doña perfecta era un perfecto desastre
cuando esto sucedió finalmente como una
epifanía lo entendí
si no lo siento
no puedo sanar
y si no lo acepto no puedo transformarlo
estar viva es sentir y si no estoy lista
para sentir nuestro y está para vivir
y sentir es darme permiso de ser humano
y ser imperfecta
de saber que no estar bien a veces está
bien
de soltar el control y darme permiso de
ser vulnerable
qué alivio qué ligereza y qué paz sentí
cuando por tiempo de soltar la espada y
el escudo quitarme la armadura de 2
toneladas y el pasamontañas y finalmente
dejar de resistir todo lo que estaba
pasando para permitirme fluir abrirme y
que las circunstancias y las situaciones
de la vida me atraviesen
y me transformo
entonces no controles
las emociones gestionarlas
no resistas acepta
gestionar tus emociones es como si le
dieras chance a tus enzimas emocionales
a que digieran y procesen la situación
para que puedas absorber sus nutrientes
y beneficiarte de ella
cuando logras hacer esto haces algo que
yo llamo alquimia emocional
y en el momento que yo me di permiso de
hacerlo
pude transformarme
a veces hay que romperse para saber de
qué estamos hechos
ya que morir a la idea hija de lo que
creíamos que éramos para poder renacer
verdaderamente somos y ser vulnerables y
auténticos
requiere valor
cuando estés en una situación donde
encuentres que estás poniendo
resistencia tienes una tarea emocional
muy alta te recomiendo lo siguiente
vamos a hacerlo respira por favor inhala
y exhala
lenta y profundamente hazlo por lo menos
tres veces y repite para ti mismo
ese y ese sí como el llamado de auxilio
de la clave morse pero en este caso
significa siente observa y suelta
siente date permiso de que la energía y
la emoción fluyan y te vengan a decir lo
que tienen que decir no los en botellas
observa date cuenta que gatillo de tono
promoción registra qué pasa en tu cuerpo
y observa también el discurso de ese
chango lo
y suelta no te identifiques con eso que
estás sintiendo porque no eres tú
ni te subas al tren de pensamientos
negativos deja que se vayan
si de plano necesitas controlar algo que
sea una rápida interna
pregúntate que yo ya me estoy contando
es una historia de terror una novela
una historia épica
el papel estoy eligiendo el de víctima o
el de enero en el propia historia
como quiero recordar esto en el futuro
y tomármelo con humor
siempre siempre las situaciones traigo
un regalo oculto decide buscarlo y
enfócate en lo que sí hay
cuando yo finalmente suelto y acepto
fluyo soy más resiliente me adapto soy
más creativa estoy abierta a las
posibles
vivo vaya
entonces por favor no controles gestiona
tus emociones
yo lo que te puedo decir el día de hoy
es que si estoy aquí después de todos
estos tsunamis de vida
si con las rodillas raspadas salen los
ojos toda mareada arenas de los calzones
y el bikini de sombrero de cualquier
forma que puedo decir estoy viva estoy
aquí y que aprendí en la mejor manera de
navegar esas aguas externas que son
inciertas es con la certidumbre y la
tabla de salvación de la aceptación la
gratitud y el cónsul internos
competí en estas donde tienes que estar
para aprender lo que tienes que aprender
y en que podrás transformar la densidad
de todas estas emociones y situaciones
adversas en oro de crecimiento personal
cuando acepto
a gancho
cuando me aceptó a mí misma me puedo
transformar
cuando decido logro las cosas
cuando agradezco mis circunstancias
atraigo bendiciones
cuando confió las cosas suceden
y cuando acudes del amor
todo fluye de controlador a controlador
nos regaló mi experiencia muchas gracias